[Musique
] c'est notre meilleure chance de trouver une
planète habitable
nous élevons et élevons notre propre équipage
[Musique]
trois trois les
entraînent isolément pour les préparer
à la vie et à l'espace
le voyage prendra 86 ans
j'ai peur
de quoi
il n'y a rien  avoir peur de
[Musique]
tu étais le lien entre les générations passées et futures et on
t'a confié la
survie de notre espèce les enfants normaux
[Musique]
sensible et intelligent
j'ai besoin de les protéger
[Musique]
il y a une toxine dans l'eau
c'est  venant de
nous nous mangeons quelque chose de toxique
c'est le bleu
c'est un médicament
pour diminuer le plaisir fleurir
je ne le bois pas
tu ne ressens pas ce que je ressens
[musique]
nous ne verrons jamais la planète que
je veux être  honnête avec lui à
propos de tout
[Musique]
il ne peut pas te
protéger nous protéger
j'ai
peur il n'y a rien à craindre
[Musique]
toi